what if Google cloud platforms machine
learning tools were all part of one
pyramid
[Music]
literally as I was trying to fall asleep
I had an idea I'm Sarah Robinson and I'd
like to help you figure out which ml
tool is right for the problem you're
trying to solve Google has a bunch of
different ml products to get you from
point A to point B in order to provide
flexibility and choosing which path you
want to take based on your cost effort
and speed requirements so I wrote it all
out really quickly then I edited it the
next day and sent it out I guess it
resonated the idea is as you move up the
pyramid less ml expertise is required
and you also don't need to worry as much
about the infrastructure behind your
model the pyramid is organized by levels
of abstraction let's start at the bottom
at the lowest level of abstraction we
have these popular open source machine
learning frameworks if you're building a
model from scratch using these
frameworks you get the flexibility of
moving your workloads across different
development and deployment environments
as a result you need to manage all the
infrastructure yourself for training and
serving if your team has very specific
needs and you have the ml engineers and
data scientists you might prefer the
total flexibility of using these
open-source ml frameworks on their own
and figuring out where to train and
serve them moving up one tier deep
learning virtual machines provide
managed click to deploy VMs for
processing data and training your model
these VMs come with popular ml
frameworks pre-installed but leave you
to figure out exactly how you'll serve
those models for instance you could
serve them on premise or directly on a
mobile device with deep learning VMs you
can reduce the overhead of managing and
allocating the compute and storage
resources required for ML workloads cube
flow is an open source project created
by Google for deploying your ml
workloads on kubernetes you use it to
configure a multi-step ml pipeline with
different components for pre-processing
data training and serving your model
because it's open source you can run it
on premise or on any cloud the other way
of saying that is what you'll still need
to do is configure where it's managed
with cube flow you can leverage the
power of containers to make your ml
stack portable reducing the operational
overhead of running your workflows AI
platform takes this where question out
of the equation it's all handled on
Google cloud platform our managed
service for all your custom model needs
AI platform is entirely serviced so you
can focus on your specific workloads and
business logic the platform includes
tools for training and serving models
most of notebooks a data labeling
service and more for example you could
take the same notebook code you're
running on premise with cube flow and
run it on GCP with AI platform notebooks
and something else I should mention you
don't have to use AI platform for both
training and serving if you wanted you
could let AI platform handle one and
figure out the other on your own for
example you could take advantage of AI
platforms TP used to train your model
and then serve it on device by the time
we get to bigquery machine learning you
no longer need a team of ML engineers
and data scientists but it might still
be helpful to have a few unlike the
products below it with BQ ml you don't
have to write any of the underlying
model code you'll still need to choose
which model type you want to use when
you run your create model query running
this query will create and train your
model and once you run it your model
will be automatically deployed for you
and available to make predictions with a
single sequel query with BQ ml you can
bring the power of ml closer to where
the data is analyzed and make it
accessible to data analysts but what if
you didn't need to write model code or
choose your model type that's where auto
ml comes in all you'll need to do is
gather and upload your data whether it's
images video text or structured data
then once you press the train button and
training completes your model is
immediately available for prediction via
an API you don't need to deploy it
yourself you can also use auto ml's UI
to evaluate your model quality and
update training data Auto ml
democratizes machine learning by
empowering more people to build custom
ml models that solve a wide variety of
business problems regardless of ML
expertise
for both auto ml and the tip of the
pyramid api's you don't need any ml
engineers or data scientists on your
team just a handful of developers what
makes our API is different from auto ml
though is that you don't need to supply
any training data yourself just make an
API request and you'll get access to pre
trained models for images video speech
text and translation
our ml api's are the easiest and fastest
way to get started with AI today I'm
Sarah Robinson and hopefully you're not
losing any sleep over choosing the
machine learning tool that's going to
help you the most
leave that part to me be sure to check
out the GCP youtube channel for more
relevant informative content and if you
found this helpful don't be afraid to
LIKE and subscribe thanks for watching
[Music]
you